Have extra-terrestrials visited our planet?
These terrifying real-life abduction stories
seem to suggest that not only have they visited,
they've been here for a while.
Watching us, experimenting on us, and even
cross-breeding with humans.
One eerie night in 1976 in rural Maine four
friends who had met at art school went on
a camping trip.
On the second night they noticed a very bright
light in the sky and then on the third night,
undeterred by the looming threat of alien
abduction, they decided to go for a spot of
night fishing.
Whilst fishing out on the canoe they noticed
the same bright light again.
One of the men used his flashlight to make
an SOS pattern at the mysterious light.
This wouldn't prove to be one of his wisest
decisions ever, because shortly afterwards
the ominous light rapidly expanded and engulfed
all four of them like an alien Pac-Man on
steroids.
The next thing the men remembered was waking
up back at their campsite with absolutely
no idea how they got there and what had happened
in-between.
The fire they had stoked up before they left
was now completely burned out and all was
left was a pile of ash.
If that doesn't scream "we've been abducted
by aliens and inexplicably lost a substantial
period of time" then I don't know what does.
But no, the four men thought nothing more
of it and finished their camping trip, acting
like everything was just fine.
But in the weeks that followed, strange things
started to happen.
Firstly, all four men started to have the
same horrific nightmares of being aboard a
spaceship with mysterious beings that had
long necks and large heads.
In each of the nightmares one of the men was
being humiliatingly experimented on whilst
the other three men helplessly watched, unable
to intervene.
It was at this point they realised something
serious went down during that camping trip.
So, disturbed by their dreams, the men later
met with a group of UFO specialists who suggested
they undergo regressive hypnosis therapy to
make all their horrific memories come flooding
back.
During the sessions all four men revealed
remarkably similar memories of being abducted
and experimented on.
Being artists all four men were able to accurately
sketch their abductors as well as the spacecraft.
All of the men's sketches were freakishly
similar.
Following psychiatric examinations the men
were all deemed to be mentally stable and
they all passed lie-detector tests.
The unnerving event has since come to be known
as the Allagash Abductions and at the time
it reached national primetime news.
Next up is the horrific story of the abductions
of Jesse Long.
Jesse Long is a man from Tennessee who claims
he was first abducted by aliens in 1957 when
he was just 5 years old.
Jesse and his brother were playing on the
hill behind his house.
When they came upon what appeared to be a
round house under construction, the two boys
obviously hadn't seen enough sci-fi horror
movies because instead of fleeing they stayed
to examine the UFO-like object closer.
Then, according to Jesse a tall man appeared
next to him and flashed him with a bright
light.
Jesse was instantly paralysed from head to
toe.
Jesse didn't remember anything more about
the event until years later when Jesse underwent
some hypnosis sessions.
During the sessions Jesse remembered himself
and his brother being led down a long hallway
then separated.
Jesse was placed on a flat table and he recalled
an object being implanted into his left shin.
The object remained inside Jesse's leg for
34 years, until, in 1991 he had an operation
to remove it from his leg.
Alas Jesse's skeptics could deny his convictions
no more, because sure enough there was a strange,
small object inside his left shin.
The object appeared to be a shard of glass.
However it was sent for further research at
a laboratory and the research came up with
some extremely bizarre results.
The South West Research Institute who examined
the supposedly alien object had this to say:
"The object had a very remarkable composition"
and it "Exhibited unique surface characteristics
that cannot be explained" and that "The questions
outnumbered the answers."
Jesse claims he has been abducted again multiple
times over the years and in one particular,
apparently extremely traumatic abduction,
Jesse was forced to crossbreed with what he
believed was a female alien being.
In 1990 Jesse Long was driving to New Orleans
right outside of Albuquerque, New Mexico,
when a light appeared and Jesse's car was
lifted off the interstate, and he was brought
up inside an alien craft, still inside his
car.
Jesse was then placed on a table and presented
with an alien baby and told "this is your
child".
Jesse wasn't sure whether they were simply
informing him of his new alien child or they
were seeking child maintenance.
Either way they seemed rather proud of what
they had accomplished.
This next case is very rare, because it's
one of the few alien abduction cases that
doesn't end in mutilation, death or weird
alien babies, it actually has a happy ending.
John Salter, Jr. was traveling on the highway
with his son, when suddenly they discovered
they were driving in the wrong direction and
they had lost an hour of time, now we all
what happens next.
The two men had no memory of what happened
during their lost hour and continued with
their journey as normal, however a little
while later they apparently saw a UFO in the
sky.
Seeing the mysterious alien craft in the air
jogged John and his son's memories and they
started to remember the strange and disturbing
events that took place during their hour of
lost time.
The two men recalled seeing a group of children
and a taller half-human, half alien creature.
However the men both said they were not afraid
of the aliens, they instead felt extremely
protected and they felt a strong connection
with the alien beings.
The two men were then guided into a room by
their new alien buddies, where they underwent
a thorough medical examination and peculiar
procedures.
However, unlike other alien abduction victims
John and his son reported an overall improvement
in their health.
But by far the weirdest part of their story,
and the thing that makes it the most believable
is that John had a scar on his forehead, however
after his abduction the scar had completely
vanished.
In most alien abduction cases the abductee
is somewhat, safely returned to Earth and
then they tell other's of their abduction.
But this adds a level of uncertainty into
the validity of their story, because they
could of course, be making it all up.
That's what makes this next case so believable,
because unlike in most abduction stories,
Frederick Valentich was never, ever seen again.
Twenty-year-old Frederick Valentich was an
aspiring pilot in Australia, until on the
21st October 1978, during a training flight
off the south-east coast of Australia something
completely unexplainable happened.
During his flight Valentich radioed Melbourne’s
Air Traffic Control to advise them that he
was being shadowed by an unidentified craft
flying about 1,000 feet above him.
Frederick said the craft was circling his
own and it was emitting an eerie green light.
He then told air traffic control that he was
experiencing engine problems.
Air traffic control asked him to describe
the other aircraft, to which Frederick replied
"it's not an aircraft" and then suddenly the
transmission was interrupted by metallic,
scraping sounds and all contact was lost.
A four day long search was undertaken of an
area 1,000 square miles large.
But no trace of Frederick Valentich or his
aircraft was ever found.
When the police questioned nearby witnesses
there were numerous reports of people sighting
a UFO in the sky above Australia on the night
of Frederick's disappearance.
And finally is the spookily convincing abduction
of Travis Walton.
Travis is an American logger who, on the 5th
November 1975, at 22 years old, was working
with a logging crew in the Apache-Sitgreaves
National Forest in Arizona.
When Travis and his crew finished for the
day they were driving home in the same truck,
when all the men spotted a bright yellowish
light from behind a hill up ahead.
They drove closer and they saw a large golden
disc hovering above a clearing.
The driver stopped the truck and Walton leaped
out and ran towards the disc, the other's
shouted at Walton to stop and come back to
the truck, but he carried on regardless.
The rest of the crew insist that they saw
a blue-green light come from the disk and
strike Walton.
Walton then rose a foot into the air with
his arms and legs outstretched and then he
disappeared, along with the hovering gold
disc.
The other men reported the incident to the
police deputy sheriff when they got home,
the sheriff reported that all the men were
distraught and two of them were in tears.
A large search party then carried out a search
for Walton over the next few days, but there
was no trace of him.
Until five days later when Travis Walton mysteriously
reappeared.
Disturbingly Walton had lost a significant
amount of weight during his five days of lost
time.
His story reached national news and he has
since wrote a book detailing his apparent
encounter with a UFO.
Thanks for the view, subscribe for more Thoughty2.